[TUP] Yle Areena.
Kun työmaat tulloo pyöräilymatkan piehän ja minähän asun Korpilahella, en tiedä milloin sinne on viimeksi rakenne. Toinen juttu, koska tämähän ei ollut ainutun, on tietenkin se, että jos Keino Äly tekisi ne työt, joku saamarin robotti vois rakentaa näitä ja ruvata pistorasia tasena, niin en mullakaan menisi hartiaat jummiin sinne kyykkiessä. Minä istusin sitten aurinkotuolissa ja joisin kaljaa. Miten asiassa ne asukkat siitä talosta vois myöskin istua aurinkotuolissa ja juo kaljaa? Eniten tarvii se tässä tasapainossa.
Niin ihan kun se äänensävy olisi tässä aika pikkuhiljaa sitten muuttunut. Jos joku aika sitten vielä kuuli innostunutta kysymystä, että mitä kaikkea se tekoäly tuleekaan meille tekemään, niin ehkä nykyään kuului vähän useammin huolestuneempaa pohdintaa, että mitä se tekoäly nyt tuleekaan meille oikein tekemään. Ainakin kun tämän ohjelman näkö tai kuulokulmasta tuleeko tekemään?.
Asiaa tarkkailee. Se on Kansanradio ja Lasse Olkinuora tässä. Tervehdys ja ihan koko Kansanradion puolesta minä tietysti toivotan hyvää äitienpäivää. Tällä kertaa täällä Kansanradiossa muuten kerrotaan täydellinen lahja äidille äitienpäivänä. Sen lisäksi ehdotetaan esimerkiksi sellaista, että eduskuntaan pitäisi palkata unilukkari tai vaihtoehtoisesti antaa ihan kaikille kansanedustajille potkut ja antaa sellaisen pienehkön virkamies- ja virkanaisporukas.
Ja voidaan hoitaa kaikki päätöksenteko tässä maassa. Mutta nyt seuraavaksi matkataan halki Suomen tai pitkin ja poikin. Kuunnellaan taas, että mikä se mietityttää missäkin lähtöpisteenä meillä Helsingin konalla ja huomautus naapureille.
No niin yksi eija tässä Helsingissä, kun mä tossa heräilin noihin naapureihin remontteihin, niin eikö todellakaan ihmiset vieläkään tiedä semmoista asiaa, että ei tarvitse käyttää näitä isku porakoneita, kun laitetaan seinään jotain kiinni.
On olemassa konstruktioterät, varmaan ammattihimiset tietävät sen, niin se menee betoniin ilman iskua ihan kevyesti. Ei naapurit häirinny eikä mitään. Muistakaa tämä. Ei mulla muuta, kiitos.
Tavossa ja siellä missä pellot on hyvin kivisiä ja muita ja on paketissa ja niistä maksetaan sitä tukea ja niillä ei mitään. Ei tuota, kun voi kukkaa. Ja minusta on fiksua siinä kun ne istutettaisiin ne kiviset vanhat pellot, niin istutettaisiin metälle, metsä kasvaisi, sieltä sai joskus tuloja, jopa verotulojakin voisi saada.
Tarkit ovat näiden päättäjien, että ei muuta. Kiitti muuten. No Ville, täältä terveiset Pohjois-Karjalasta ja kiitokset Orpolle, kun on hoitanut täällä nämä työllisyysasiat hyvin. Tuskin täällä on yhtään työtöntä ainakaan tässä kunnossa, jossa olen taloyhtiön vuokralaisena. Täällä pitää asukkaan hoitaa liputuspäivinä, liputushommat. Olen 88 vuodessa.
Puotias ja huki on minun tehtävän. Laitoin almanakkaan ylös, että muistan juhannuksena nostaa lipun salkoon. Onhan minulla synteet. Täällä vanhuksetkin tekee työt. Kaikille hyvää jatkoa. Heippa hei.
säästöjä huomattavasti työterveyshuolto alas. Olen itse ollut töissä ihan lapsesta vanhuuden asti ja seurannut tätä hommaa minun omassa työyhteisössä. Kuinka hyväksi käytetään sitä, että kuinka on helppo pirhauttaa, jos on pääkipiä, rapulaa, jotakin asioita mitä haluaa hoijella, että enpä lähde töihin. Me soitamme työterveyteen, niin sieltä tulee heti. Me valehtellen, että on
että nyt pitää kyllä, nyt on huono olo kyllä, että sieltä lipsahtaa heti kolme päivää, neljä päivää eikä mitään, sen kummempaa.
Jos ihminen on töissä, sillä on varaa maksaa oikeasti sairastuessa se sama poliimaksu, minkä maksaa eläkeläiminkin nyt, varsinkin kun lähdetään tuonne vasta-otolle odottamaan, jos sinne yleensä pääsee muutaman päivän päästä.
Arvon pääsee heti, mutta jos pääsee niin kyllä mie maksan mielihyvin sen polimaksun, mutta haluan että sen maksaa työntekijäkin ja työterveys alas vapautuu lääkäreitä ja vapautuu kaikkia ja asiat ja säästöä tulleepi, ei muuta.
Hieno pilvinen keli, lämmintä ja kevät on ja kohta on kesä. No näin on, kyllä kelpaa. On tässä kuukausia jo miettinä, että ket onko tämä asia elimässä, kun meitähän on vain jo kuusi miljoonaa tässä Suomessa ihmistä, niin minun mielestäni tämä meidän poliittinen järjestelmä tuolla eduskunnassa ja yleensäkin, niin meillä on liian iso se, niin eihän se tällä tavalla oikein nämä asiat minusta eteneet.
-Eli minkälaista muutosta toivotte? - Tehtäisiin nyt semmoinen poliittinen päätös, että kun nyt on vuuven piästynyt vaalit, niin laskautetaan neljäksi vuotta tämä poliittinen järjestelmä ja viisikymmentä virkanaista ja viisikymmentä virkamiestä siellä ministeriössä rupeaisi tämän maan asioita hoidamaan. - Kuka heidät siis valitsee? - Ne virkamiehet ja virkanaisethan siellä jo istuvat varassa aikkoon, mitä laki eli säännökset lakiehtoivat.
Esitykset ja lait valmisteet ja sitten vaan tää meidän suuri eduskunta napinpainatuksena hyväksyy tulevaisuudessa. - Nämä henkilöt säilyvät siellä ja kansanedustajille sanotaan, että muita hommia.
Ei muita hommia. Pannaan tuota tuonne kokeilemaan tuonne kortistohommiin. Ei mitään palakkiovirkoja eikä mitään. Että vähän hyölähtöä kansapuhtolta. Toivotaan ehdittämään niitä töitä. - Aika suuri muutos? - Aika suuri muutos, mutta kokeiltaisiin. Kokeiltaisiin. Jos ei tämä homma pelaa, niin sitten tuota parataan tähän edelleen järjestelmään. - Me jäädään kuuntelemaan, että mitä sanoo Kansanradion -kansanvaliokunnassa.
- Kuuntelija tästä ehdotuksesta. Sen voi sanoa tästä ehdotuksesta, että ainakaan tässä ei vaan viilata yksityiskohtia vaan kyseessä on ihan täysremontti.
- Niin, semmoinen neljä vuoden remontti. Katsottais kahden vuoden päästä, että jos on ihan metässä tää homma, niin tuota voidaan me sitten vaalit järjestää.
- Niin.
- Mm. Mm. Hyvä, kiitoksia sinulle ja päivän jatkoon sinä varmaan muuten.
- Me toivotellaan päivän jatkot.
Tämän meidän Kansanradion yhteystiedot, ne minä kerron sitten tuolla ohjelman loppupuolella, niin tiedät, että mihinkä numeroon, mihinkä osoitteeseen vastata, jos haluat vastata vaikkapa nyt sitten seuraaviin kysymyksiin tai ihmettelyn aiheisiin.
Seija on laittanut meille viestin, että minä en jaksa ymmärtää, miten monet taiteilijoiksi itseään kuvittelevat halveksivat katsojiaan tulemalla resuisissa vaatteissa esiintymään.
Heidän menestyksensähän riippuu katsojista. Vaatejakelusta saisi varmaan ehjiä vaatteita vinkiksi vain, näin päättää viestinsä Seija.
Suivoko muita, puolestaan kysyi ukkeli Orivedeltä. Eli olisin kysellyt seuraavaa asiaa, kun suivoo niin ristuksesti, että kun rupeaa lukea puhelimesta uutisia tai mitä vaan tietoa, niin pompsahtaa heti joku iltalehden tai iltasanomien plus toiminto, että maksa nyt vielä, että pääset lukemaan sen asian. Rahastusta koko touhu en maksa, kiitos.
Semmosta asiaa ollaan mietitty, tästä on paljon ennenkin puhuttu, mutta pitäisi nostaa uudelleen esille nämä yleiset roskapöntöt, korit millä näitä nyt sanois täällä maantien varrella, niin pitäisikö niihin laittaa jotain kuin kamerat, kun tuntuu, että ihmiset saatana vie tälleen kesämäkijän kauden jälkeen vuonekalujakin sinne ja ihan kaikkea muuta mahdollista, niin johan toivoo sakotettavaa toimintaa, että puheenaihetta siitä, kiitos.
No hei Raimo tässä. Yllätön kun kävin Lidissä alkukuusta, ostin saskia hiilihaputetun vesipullon, hinta kuusikymmentäkuusi senttä. Nyt kävin uudestaan, niin sama pullo maksoi euro yksitoista senttä. Hinta oli nousunut neljäkymmentäviisi senttiä, eli yhden litralle tulee hinnankortoitu noin kolmekymmentä senttiä ja seitsemänkymmentä prosentin kortutut alkuperäiseen hintaan.
Lidi ei ole pystynyt vastaamaan tähän, mistä korotustun johtuu, koska ei ole mitään maksukysäteitä. Omaa pelkkä korotettu, tommoinen hiilihapetettu vesipullo. Ihmettelen kovasti, kiitos.
Täällä tuohtunut akka. Kyllä elämä tehdään vaikeaksi ja mikään vaikeaksi. Kun pankki vaatii asiakaspietoja yli kahdeksankymppiseltä ihmiseltä, sillä pitäisi olla toi.
Tietokone sen pitäisi jaksaa juosta pankkiin tekemässä asiakastiedot. Sairas kun on, ei vääse. Ja sitten kun pyytää puhelimetsä paperiversiota, se puhelumaksu maksaa yli kaksi euroa ja paperiversioonkin täytyy olla vielä tulostettu henkilötiedot, siis henkilökortissa tiedot. Mistä nämä kaikki johtuvat?
Että kaikkia vaaditaan vanhoilta ihmisiltä, jolla ei ole tietokonetta eikä lykännykkää eikä jaksa enää. Minkä takia tätä asiakastietoa aina pitää päivittää? Moi, kahdeksankymmentä plus täällä. Ihmettelen, onko Suomen antiikkimarkkinat ollenkaan kansainvälisellä tasolla ja kuka heille, jotka antiikkia täällä Suomessa hoitavat.
Maksaa palkan, koska mikään antiikki mikä on pienet isot, mikään ei heille kelpaa myyntiin. Eikö heidän pitäisi palvella asiakkaita ja ottaa toimeksi annon, jos joku haluaa, että hänen antiikkinsa myydään? He vaan käy katsomassa ja tarkistamassa, että onko mitään ja sanoo, että ei me mitään myydä.
mutta jostain ne palkansa saa. Kiitos hei. Voiskohan saemaan Norppia istuttaa Päijänteeseen, Oulujärveen tai Inari järveen. Palataan seuraavaksi viime viikkoiseen lähetykseen. Ei suinkaan ainoa aihe joka puhututti, mutta erityisesti se ehdotus äänestys yläikärajasta sai ihmiset soittelemaan laittamaan viestiä muitakin reittejä. Hiukan suivaantunut yli seitsemänkymmentän
vuotias kysyy viestissään, että mitäpä jos tehtäisiin sellainen laki, että kaikkien alle 35-vuotiaiden olisi pakko äänestää, kun tuntuu, että nuoriso ei ymmärrä, että jättämällä äänestämättä annat toisen mielipiteen esittäjälle kaksinkertaisen vaikutusmahdollisuuden, koska se vastaehdotus puuttuu.
Hyvä tässä kuuluu, mutta kun kuuntelen kansanradioa ja mua naurattaa tällainen asia, tämä nyt on varmasti jo vanha juttu, mutta tällainen kuin tää budjettiriihi, niin mun mielestä se on kyllä helkkarin huono mielikuvitus. Se on varmasti jostain keskitty, keksitty kolmekymmentä luulla joku. Ihmä edes nää mitkä siellä istuu päättämästä asiat tiedä, mikä edes Elvetin riihi on.
Onko sulla mahdollisesti sitten jotain toista nimiehdotusta? No mun mielestä kun ne istuu tuolla, minä tiedän kun mä olen Helsingistä, niin tuossa Snellmanin kaduilla siellä talossa, niin eikö sen voi sen talon mukaan kuule päättää? Niin kuin se, että tää olisi siellä missä ne todella istuu ja päättää asioita. Ja sitten tuota toinen asia, mikä mä oon nyt tässä kyllä yhden viikon myöhässä, mutta kun puhuin täällä.
Puhuttiin näistä murteista. Mä ymmärrän kyllä, että ihmiset puhuvat murteista, mutta minun mielestä Yleisradion toimittajan pitäisi kyllä suunnilleen puhua kirjakieltä, eli toimittajien kirjakieltä. Niin kyllä minun mielestäni pitäisi puhua kirjakieltä eikä mongertaa jotain savua tai karjalaa tai mitä ne nyt sitten tekevätkään. Joo, eli esimerkiksi Yleisradiossa pidetään sellainen yhteinen linja kirjakieltä. Minun mielestäni.
- No niin. Kirjakieli Ylelle ja budjettiriihin sijaan se olisi sitten... - Missä ne pojat päättävät ja tytät niistä asioista? Eikö se ole se tota... - Säätytalon budjetti. - Säätytalon budjetti minun mielestä enkä mikään Helkarin riihin. - No niin. - Minun ainakin lapset, lapset ei enää tiedä mikä helvetin riihi on. - Siinä kaksi ehdotusta. - Okei kiitos. - Mainio juttu, päivä jatkuu. - Kiitos sinulle.
- Kiitos, heilua, moi. - No Tommi tässä Hämeestä vaan terve. Tälle kaverille, joka ehdottaa yläikärajaa äänestämiseen, niin tällaista lakia ei ole missään maapallon maassa. En ymmärrä, mitä tämä henkilö tarkoittaa tällä, että Suomeen laitettaisiin yläikäraja äänestäjille. Tämähän on aivan naurettava.
Minä toivon, että kaikki veteraanit ja sodan aikana syntyneet ja sodan jälkeen syntyneet ihmiset soittavat nyt ja lähettävät viestiä kansanradioon. Tämähän on aivan naurettava ehdotus. Tälle henkilölle, joka näin ehdottaa, minä ehdotan hänelle vuoden aikana.
naurettavinta ehdotuspalkintoa. - Sunnuntain kolmas viidettä, 26. Vastaus mielipiteeseen, jossa soittaja väheksyy yli 75-vuotien äänioikeutta.
Juurikin ikäihmisillä on viisautta, elämänkokemusta karttunut. Fiksuja kannanottoja ollut, kun minä ystäväni kanssa olemme haastatelleet ikäihmisiä Turuilla ja Toreilla.
Ehdotuspalkintojen ihmiset ovat hyvää aineesta. Kaikille 18- 100-vuotiaille pitää olla edelleenkin äänioikeus. Häpeä sinä, joka väheksyit yli 75-vuotiaiden äänioikeutta. Harrastit ikärasismia.
- Timo Tampereelta huomenta. Viimeksi Kansanradiosta puhuttiin kuunvaloitasta ja piirteinvaloitetta. Kansanradiosta puhuttiin kuunvaloitetta.
Niin kuuntelin palautetta, jossa henkilö ehdotti, että kuussa voi olla myös etu ja takapuoli. Niin tuli mieleen 60-luvun alakoulu Johanneksen kansakoulussa asianomaisesta aiheesta. Johtajaopettaja Sarjasto kysyi, mitkä puolet ovat maapallolla. Viittasimme ja opettaja kiersi luokkaa pitkin ja kysyi minulta, mitä puolet ovat.
- Timo, no mitä puolet ovat maapallolla, vastasin etu ja takapuoli. Siitäkös se riemu alkoi ja itse pääsin jälkiistuntoon. Joutukohan asianomainen henkilö myös aikoinaan jälkiistuntoon. Terveisin Juhannuskylän kansakoulusta, Timo. Kiitos.
Meille saapunut sähköpostia, jonka lähettäjä kertoo olevansa aktiivinen Ylen ykkösen ohjelmien kuuntelija, podcastaja ne kai nykyään on. Ammattitoimittajat ovat hyviä, mutta rasittaa ihan satasella nuo kaiken maailman asiantuntijat ja erikoisasiantuntijat. Johtuukohan se tämä tästä Tik Tok -ajasta, kun puhuvat lausunnoissaan kuin tykinsuusta ja usein kyseessä nuoremmat tyypit. Tai sitten olen itse vaan hidas. En jaksa, en pysty seuraamaan sitä tykinsuusta.
Ja Suomen kielen hyvä taito on myös usein hukassa. Joku uuden sukupolven juttu selkeästi. Tuutatkoon muilla kanavilla, mutta ei näillä perinteisillä ja Ylen pitäisi kiinnittää huomiota tähän ja suomen kieli ja tiedonvälitys kunniaan.
Voiko ohjelma olla miellyttävämpi? Kiitos elämänpiisintekijöille kaikille. Se oli kaunista illanpelastus. Ei, ei.
Radiossa kysyin myöskin, että pitäisikö haittatyökorvaukset muuttaa vastaavaksi vapaa-ajaksi, jotta työllisyystilanne voitaisiin pelastaa. Tässä on niin paljon pelastettavaa, että tässä ollaan kohta orjatyövoimaa kaikki. Mutta ollaan oltu vaikeammassakin tilanteessa tässä maassa.
Ja moni muu, että nämä tunnarit, mitä soitetaan välimusiikkina ennen ja jälkeen esimerkiksi uutiset iltapäivisin ja urheiluruudun välissä, korvat ovat kovilla. Voisiko vaihtaa vaikka kesäksi pätkän kesäillan valssia, syksyllä syysillan tuuli, jouluna voisi olla jouluista, talvella vaikka jänojussin mäenlaskua ja keväällä linnunlaulua. Jotain muuta kuin mitä nyt on.
eikä jaksa aina vaihtaa kanavaa. Me kuitenkin maksetaan Yle veroa, olis kiva kun tunnarit vaihtuis ja sais kuulla mitä halutaan.
Ja sitten vielä onneksi voi kääntää kanavan kun Arttu viskari huutaa ja kirruo naama punaisena perkelettä siellä Suomelle.
Siellä voisi olla Finlandiassa turhanpäiväistä uhoamista, muuten hyvä kappale mutta perkeleet pois ja siellä televisiossa se taustaväritys silmissä ihan vilisee, tulee huono olo kun se siellä taustalla takana virkkuilee reippa mummeli.
Ja tämä on ihan järkyttävää kun tähän saadaan korjausta että viljelijät kärsii ja sato menee ja ne tuhoavat kaiken että miksi näitä voidaan nyt sitten antaa lupa että niitä ammutaan ja sitten voitais vaikka ne syödä.
Arttun mieleen että nälhätä uhkaa, miksi niitä voidaan pakastaa ja sitten lähettää vaikka nälkäsille muualle maailmaan eli Suomessa saa niitä syödä. Tämmöinen mielipide oli minulla nyt päällimmäisenä.
Tämä on ihan asia ja kauheat korvaukset sitten maksetaan. No hyvä tietysti sitten maksetaan viljelijät tarvitsevat ne mutta siis tämä on niin kun naudettavaa että Suomessa ei ole kyllä maalaisjärkeä vaikka maalaisasiasta puhutaan. No niin kiitoksia. Toivottavasti että tähän otetaan kantaa ja tulee korjausta. Heippa.
Aivan liian kalliita. Tämä näkyy terveydessä ja jaksamisessa. Me siis tarvitsemme lisää matalan kynnyksen liikuntamahdollisuuksia jotta kaikki pääsevät mukaan. Sellainen ehdotus Kalevilta lisää ehdotuksia luvassa seuraavaksi. Suurin osa näistä ehdotuksista kohdistuu tuonne Arkadianmäen suuntaan. Eivät kaikki mutta suurin osa. Kansanradio.
Terve Ritva. Tätä noin ennen vanhaan kirkoissa oli unilukkari joka herätteli niitä ihmisiä kun nukahtivat pitkän saarannan aikana ja kepillä herätteli. Ja mitä te jos kansanedustajien herättelteis näillä tavoin että unilukkari herättäis niitä jotka nukahtaa.
- Että siellä olisi eduskuntatalossa kaveri Kepin kanssa ja jos meinaa huolio herpaantua niin se käy tökkäävässäkin. No niin. - Hei vaan. - Kiitos, hei.
- Siitä on puhuttu siitä eduskunta, eduskunnan kansanedustajavalehtelusta. Siitähän on tehty kirjakin ja aika erikoistahan on, että esimerkiksi eduskunnan puhemies sanoo, että täällä ei saa.
Eduskunnassa ei saa sanoa toista valehtelijaksi, mutta ei kiellä sitä. Valehella saa vaikka kuinka paljon niin kuin ne tekeekin sitä. Ja jos ajatellaan, että nää ihmiset on jonkin verran koulua käyneet ja jopa akateemisiksi voi sanoa, mutta ne varmaan on lukenut vähän väärää lajia, kun on lukenut näitä yhteiskunta- ja valtiotieteille, että olisi pitänyt lukea laskentatieteilijöitä, kauppatieteilijöitä. Mutta pitähän tää saada loppua ja ainoa konsti.
Siihen on, että aina kun tulee näitä rankäyksiä isojakin kurjan näköstä kuunnella, niin siellä olisivat asianmukaiset faktantarkastajat, jotka kertovat miten se asia oikeasti on. Muulla tavalla tämä ei lopu. Kiitos, hei.
Täällä on yhdeksänkymmentäyksi vuotias mummo. Kerron tuolle päiviräsäselle. Tulee jo 2000-luvulle. Et ole seurannut, kuinka lahjakkaita homot on. Maailman kuuluvia muotitaiteilijoita, maalareita, näyttelyjä, opera-laulajia, kirjailijoita. Yhden muita taideammattia. Päivi, älä käytä mitään kulttuuria. Älä täytä mitään asuja, jos ne on vaikka homon suunnittelemia. Sinä päivi.
Ei, traamatun, sodan Jumalan alttarille. Kiitos.
- Hoivakodissa asuva mummo. Ihmettelen sitä, että hoivakodissa on työpaikkoja, -
mutta suomalaisille ei kelpaa. Työttömyyskorvausut niiltä pois, jos sen kerran työ kelpaa. Töitä on. Suurin osa on ulkomaalaisia, jotka -
tässäkin hoivakodissaan tekee töitä. Suomalaisille ei kelpaa. Ei kelpaa työ.
- Nyt kaikille mummoille ja äiteilleni ruokatermari äihienpäivälahjaksi. Sillä voi tehdä kaikkea. Eli puuro aamulla, illalla vaan vähän lämmittää. Sitä saa puuron tehtyä. Sitten saa keitettyä riisit. Sitten saa keitettyä makaroohit. Enää ei tarvitse käyttää paljon mitäsähköä. Tällainen on hyvä ruokatermari. Ei muuta -
Tämän kertaisen Kansanradion loppuun kuullaan kaksi viestiä nuorille, sen jälkeen yksi viesti ihan koko kansalle. Niitä ennen lupaamani yhteystiedot. Meidän WhatsApp se on 044 5515464. Sähköpostit osoitteeseen kansan.radio.at/yle.fi. Lyijykynällä tai kuulakärkikynällä kirjoitetut kirjeet ja kortit voi lähettää osoitteeseen
kansan radio pl 7 9 000 24 Yleisradio. Ja se meidän vastaaja se on 08 0 0 1 5 4 6 4. Siellä se ihmisvastaaja sitten odottelee sunnuntaina lähetyksen päättymistä että pääsee vastaamaan juuri sinun puheluun.
Ei ole vielä tällä hetkellä että on kevät kun tuo koivun siitepöly päätti minulta viedä väliaikaisesti hajuaistin kuten perinteisiin kuuluu. Mutta ainakin tuo ulkona kevältä näyttää ja kiitos komeiden lintukuorojen siltä se kuulostaa. Voi hyvin. Tässä on vanha vaadia. Harmittaa noi nuoria kun niillä on hienot puhelimet mutta ei niillä soittaa voi mihinkään kun ei ainoa äänettämällä ei kukaan vastaa kun yritetään soittaa.
Kaansa radio. No heippa kuulepa sellainen asia poiketaan kaikista näistä nyt näistä jutuista mitä on kuultu. Niin kato kun on äitiipäivätulossa ja moni mummikin on yksinään siellä on hoitanut lapsen lapsia ja lapsenlapsia ja nuorilla on kaikilla älypuhelimet ja sitten tällä mummelillakin on älypuhelin niin voisiko nämä nuoret laittaa vaikka.
Iloisen tekstiviestin tälle mummille koska ne on hirveän tärkeitä asioita koska niitä korttia ei enää kirjoitella vaikka se olisi kyllä aivan ihana kun sais kortin. Eli huomautus kaikille nuorille tai miksei nyt oikeastaan ihan kaikille muillekin että. Niin niinku lapsillekin ja lapsenlapsille. Rohkaistuiskohan vaikka nyt tiedän että nykyään ei ole kovinkaan suosittua soittaa puhelimella mutta rohkaistuiskohan ne äitien päivänä jopa suosittuessa.
No ei voi ehkä ne ei soitakaan mutta vois vaikka laittaa sen tekstiviestin niin säilyyhän se tekstiviesti ja joku kivaa kuvaa sieltä löytyy paljon hauskoja juttuja. On emojia kaikkia niin säilyyhän se kuva siellä. Sitten mummi voi katsoa niitä sieltä tekstiviestiosastolta. Ei se paljoa vaadi. No ei se kuule paljoa vaadi kun ne on aina puhelimessa. Niin se on kyllä totta joo. Niin kerta siinä koko ajan.
Koko ajan on puhelin kädessä niin miksipä ei sitten. Niin hyvä mutta ei muuta kuin ennalta jo kaikille äidille ja mummille on paljon onnea. Minä kiitän kun soititte ja päivänjatot. Moi! Hei!
Mutta tiedämmekö mikä vaara siellä vaanii? Se on se pieni olematon näköinen katala punkki. Punkkilahan on kaksi kantavaa kohtalokasta sairautta TBE ja Borrelios. TBE:n on saatava rokotte toisilla alueilla ilmaiseksi ja toisilla ei.
Niin kuin se oli tehtiin poliolle. Muistan saani sokeripala jo aikuis iässä mutta se Borrelios sehän on vasta katala. Muistakaa et jos punkki on purrut tai jos on viitteitä siitä niin jos sen saa ajossa lääkitetty niin siitähän selviä. Olkaa kovia ja taistelkaa!
Olkoon se mikä tahansa siis punkin jäljeltä jättämä oire. Mä en oikein ymmärrä miksei sitä Borreliosa voi ottaa vähän vakammin niin sehän on semmoinen pirrullinen säisaus. Kiitos!